yeah the family is the oldest and
arguably most influential religious
political organization Washington dates
back to the Great Depression in 1935
when a the founders group had what he
thought was a new revelation the
Christianity had been looking in the
wrong direction for 2,000 years focusing
on the poor and the weak and the
down-and-out that God instead wanted him
to work God wanted to work through
elites through those whom he called the
up-and-out and that he should be a
missionary to and for the powerful and
that's what the family has been ever
since concentrating not on mass revivals
but on organizing congressman
businessmen foreign officials and today
in Washington the membership is
comprised primarily of Senators and
Representatives and government officials
who are bound with this together in this
idea that what they see as spiritual
warfare they call us sometimes or
religious change can best be effected
through elites not through mass
movements
Elite fundamentalism is always going to
be involved with a certain set of
conservative interest but certainly not
exclusively Republican and you know
what's interesting about the family and
why the family is a particularly useful
group for going back and reviewing the
history of conservatism is it while it's
always been majority Republican it's
never been exclusively Republican back
in the early days there was a lot of the
so-called Dixiecrats the the
conservative Pro segregation Southern
Democrats strom thurmond was involved
Herman Talmadge Absalom Willis Robertson
the senator from Virginia and Pat
Robertson's father and today I think
what's interesting is the populist
movement of fundamentalism is starting
to mirror that approach that elite
fundamentalism has long had of trying to
you know have influence across the
political spectrum and understanding
that when you do that you can drag the
whole political spectrum right word so
the family's always been doing this
always cultivating certain Democrats and
I think now we're starting to see
populace conservatives recognize that
they were 22 tied to the Republican
Party so there's the Republican partisan
activists but then there's the real
conservative sort of visionaries for
lack of a better word they don't care
who does the changes they want to see
happen they don't care if it's senator
chuck grassley standing in the door and
walking Obama's legislative changes or
if it's Senator Mark Pryor a Democrat
from Arkansas who was arguably one of
the key men in scuttling a big part of
Obama's a labor agenda in fact I think
they take great satisfaction from the
idea that there's Democrats and
Republicans involved because then this
is testifying to the sort of the
universal truth of their cause they say
in fact what we're saying isn't
conservative or liberal it's not it's
not right-wing or left-wing it's simply
true and all these Republicans know in a
bunch of
no that too
fundamentalism has always been on the
corporate side of things but what that
does is tell us that these things that
this divide is not nearly so sharp as
you know maybe David Brooks would have
us believe that there's some some rabble
out there and then there's some
high-minded proper Republicans you know
the family begins as a Christian
fundamentalist anti-labor organization
it begins with a bunch of bosses getting
together and saying we're going to break
labor spine and that we're doing this
for Jesus this is what Jesus wants so
it's the rhetoric that maybe that you're
familiar with from the fights over
abortion but being applied to corporate
interests and service of what the family
in particular but also other religious
conservatives would come to call over
the years biblical capitalism the idea
that capitalism is for deigned in the
Bible and the in as much as we interfere
with the market we're interfering with
God's very literal invisible hand God's
ability to move the hearts of a big
business people and and have them do the
right thing that instead of relying on
government programs or labor unions or
any kind of activism we should rely on
Jesus to move the hearts of these
leaders and that they will then dispense
the blessings to the rest of us it was
sort of trickle-down trickle-down
economics and trickle-down religion and
that's influenced the shape of populist
conservatism at this point too i mean i
remember a few years ago I was in a mega
church in Colorado Springs a Ted
Haggard's church before Ted Haggard's
fall was for very prominent pastors no
longer so prominent actor came out that
he was having a relationship with a male
prostitute but at the time Haggard had
managed to get the eleven thousand or so
members of his church all riled up over
the issue of steel terrace steel tariffs
that was that was the issue steel
terrorists were violating God's plan and
these weren't wealthy people these were
mostly working class people
so that's that kind of trickle-down
religion in action and showing that you
can you can recruit the populist
conservatism for the interests of
corporate conservatism that the two
things can be married in two into one
unholy Union
I think you have to put everything you
know we are still living in an era
defined by the Cold War the Cold War was
was really the great struggle of the
20th century and it and it it just
shaped American political life from top
to bottom and what the Cold War did was
provide a really fairly clearly defined
enemy and it's easy to organize around
that and what's interesting is of course
not only did conservatives organized
around that liberals did too liberals
were just as engaged and using the
rhetoric of a sort of a battle with with
the Soviets and with communism in
general with an evil empire the plenty
Democrats use the evil empire rhetoric
as well and this interesting thing
happens with the collapse of communism
especially in the sort of the the really
activist ranks of Christian
fundamentalism which was really the base
for conservative activism well who's the
enemy now and so they've been sort of
casting about now for for some years
trying to figure out how to define
themselves and there was this action
moment I mentioned before this church
out in Colorado Springs New Life Church
several years ago they had a it was a
summit of about 3,000 pastors around the
country and the debate at the summit was
what is the front line of the struggle
for America's soul America's future what
is the great threat because you got have
a threat and there were two choices the
gay man and they you always hear this
individual spoken of his in the singular
the gay man like this is one guy who is
subverting everything it's an archetype
or the Muslim the game enter the Muslim
and that's been a attention in the right
for a while now and what I think is
happening is it's slowly sort of
coalescing around the side that would
make struggle with Islam the main fight
and
because that reproduces some of the
Alliance's it were made possible by the
Cold War because there's Democrats in
those liberals who are every bit as sort
of anti-islamic as the hard ride is
there is a the real you know there are
real radical Muslim groups out there
that really are pretty villainous you
know you don't have to make them up but
as they do that that really it
replicates some of the Cold War but it's
not a perfect fit and and I think as
they sort of struggle with that issue it
sort of explodes things out outward so
you have this one issue this sort of
this Muslim threat well that allows
people to talk about national security
so you go to like a town hall or a tea
party meeting and you have folks talking
about big government and so on but also
speaking an incredibly precise detail
about America's missile Arsenal and
missile defense and and this becoming an
issue and linking that to the question
not just of health care but of public
schools I mean really I think one of the
overlooked struggles on the right now is
the longtime dream of the eradication of
public schools which they're not ever
going to that's not going to happen or
at least Im soon but look how far
they've come you know look how much that
right word push has shifted the debate
so that public schools are probably have
less government support now then they
have certainly in our lifetimes and and
going back many decades so all these
kinds of little issues that are somehow
being linked to the great enemy and
their their mind of Islam that Islam
requires us to get our house in order
and our house in order means we need
education that is going to teach about
real menace and public schools can't do
that it means we need this vigorous free
market
and it's all for the sake of national
security
fundamentalism is a 20th century
phenomenon but that kind of religious
fervor actually has not always been
associated with conservative goals and
you know as Christian right activists
are quick to point out they say look it
was evangelicals who are on the front
lines of the fight for abolition and the
antebellum period and that's true I mean
you even go back to the sort of the
defining moment the the creation moment
of us kind of modern fundamentalism
which is the Scopes Monkey Trial 1925
you know this is the evolution try over
over whether or not when teach creation
in schools and Tennessee and so on and
we all have this sort of popular
narrative of this event Clarence Darrow
as the great lawyer and champion of
justice vs crazy William Jennings Bryan
the old Fundamentalist and blustering on
about the Sun standing still and monkeys
and all this kind of stuff and that
narrative obscures the fact that what
happened in 1925 wasn't left versus
right it was too great strands of
leftist thought an American life
clashing they up to that moment William
Jennings Bryan lame Jennings Bryan was
the most successful populist
presidential candidate in American
history had a lot of ugly ideas but had
also a lot of very progressive ideas
he's a guy leaves the Wilson
administration because he sees it as two
imperialist and he represents a leftist
tradition of fundamentalism that gets
kind of lost at that at that point
because I think liberals sort of
coalesce around this other idea that we
own reason that we own the center that
we are the establishment and so there's
really nowhere else for that energy to
go now but the right because liberalism
has for so long to find the
establishment and then you also have the
problem that liberalism can't ever it
can it can own the center but it can't
ever mobilize the same energy you know
who's going to go marching out in the
street and say you know what do we want
and
criminal reform when do we want it over
a graduated period of time you know it
doesn't energize folks it doesn't speak
to the visionary aspect of American life
it doesn't speak to ideals liberalism
doesn't speak to ideals radicalism does
leftism does and some other movements
you know the once in the former labor
movement there isn't much of a labor
movement now which wasn't exactly left
but it did speak to these sort of
visionary ideals and it was able to
organize a lot of people even now it's
still able to organize a lot of people
just not nearly as many